hello everyone we are back in Austin at
South by Southwest
and right now we have to take a moment
to thank our fine sponsors like hint
water because because of them we are
here at the festival we get to talk
about movies like good boys and I am so
excited to see your movie I just saw the
red band trailer earlier today and wow
this looks like something else Jean I
wanted to start with you on this because
it's a very big deal to jump into your
first feature and I know you have a lot
of experience in other capacities but
what was it about this particular story
that made you say this was my one I
really you know Lee and I were looking
to do something that got us excited we
wanted to make a movie that we wanted to
see and that actors in the movie
couldn't see so that combination was
hard to come by so yeah but we did it do
you guys remember the first r-rated
movie you ever saw mine was Caddyshack
my father yeah I don't know if your
dad's here but that's an A+ choice for a
first r-rated was probably not from way
back then I imagine I feel like if
poltergeist was rated PG there's no way
jaws was right at all rated PG probably
the worst one was probably sausage
can you guys tell me and especially for
our audience who doesn't know very much
about this movie just yet a little
something about your characters and
what's your favorite thing about them my
favorite thing about my character is
probably how nice and sweet he is but
closer to the end he starts like you
know going through some stuff because
his parents get a divorce so yeah I like
my character because he's kind of the
bad boy and me and him are have some
similarities and differences Brady is
not allowed to curse at all but at all
like I get punished like I get my game
taken away like my ps4 like I get I get
punished because we we all had a rule
kind of on set what set on set stays on
set so we all kind of just abide by that
but I mean there are pretty funny too
that's kind of really what I like about
my character is that he's kind of like
almost like he's he's the one that's
like really growing up out of the three
and he's really lovestruck
so he's worrying about girls and
everything and something that we have in
common would probably be the if I'm
being honest like what is it about a
story like this that you guys thought
needed to be told through younger eyes
especially because I had just seen
book-smart I'm a huge fan of super bed
and it you know it doesn't feel like
we've ever had this kind of story told
from such a young perspective before and
that kind of excites me we talked we
talked a lot about our time in sixth
grade and middle school and how awkward
and confusing it is it's like you have a
little bit of knowledge and you're
starting to kind of grow up but you
don't quite know everything and it's
super awkward and awkward comedy awkward
and comedy worked pretty well together
yeah that's for sure curious now for you
guys what makes you feel the most
awkward or uncomfortable is there
anything that makes you think you know I
don't know I'm like I'm not fitting in
or I'm doing something weird
no if we if we ever
all done a full week on they were
everyone was pretty open about it like
we could say we're not comfortable and
they just change your reword something
it's a good thing to have them set yeah
yeah sometimes like yeah pretty much
what Brady said it's also I would ask my
mom about stuff and if I didn't need to
know what that was I figured out
eventually when I'm older but if there
was something that she was fine with me
knowing about she would explain it to me
like what some bad words mean and what
sick some things are used for all right
pretty much explains my mind is going
out of control based on what I saw in
the trailer this morning okay when I
have that uncomfortable but you know you
have things that you don't want to like
talk about so you just had to be like
mature about it and like ask questions
and we were all very professional about
it I would believe it do you guys have
any kind of movies that inspired your
character at all or movies that you
thought of while you were working on
this one for me probably stand by me
because I could they could have like
same relationship but they both go on an
adventure but Stan might be is more of a
drama good blaze is like a big big
comedy where they're just doing stupid
stuff the whole time for me I kind of
related to Superbad and Jonah Hill
because he was most like my character I
think and I would kind of watch like
certain things he'd say he would say in
like a sarcastic but straight tone so I
would always watch him and how he acted
and I got it took a took some stuff from
him and I put it in here I just realized
something
further when we did the paintball scene
were out shooting people with paintballs
I actually watched the some of the fight
scenes from the matrix with Keanu Reeves
when he when he has the gun yeah I I
watched that so if you when you watch
that scene you can tell like I'm
harnessing
like Keanu yeah like in my facial
expression isn't in the way I move
that's how I got ready for that scene
it's a good skill set to have if you're
playing paintball I think mine was
natural but also kind of like mclovin in
the movie Superman yeah I don't know
well not all the way cuz McLovin was
like I don't know how we related but I
just felt like that my character was
kind of like he was like the conscience
of the group yeah it's a really big deal
to have a movie like this hitting
theaters and you've got some really
experienced people by your side here is
there anybody that gave you a little bit
of advice in terms of just getting ready
for this big release my mom probably my
mom probably um my mom - what did your
mom tell you I remember my mom would
always just say stay humble and that's
that's something that I really want to
continue doing you know because I feel
like if you're humble that's that's
where you're gonna excel the most at and
get more jobs for me I think my mom gave
me the advice don't be afraid to swear
just go for it and movies like these
never too much oh yeah I took that
advice my mom gave me that swear that
I'm just swearing in the movie it's not
like it's not like I'm swearing outside
of my character my character swearing
not me
so basically why first started the
audition I just prayed about it
afterwards pray that you don't say I
know every time I audition room I go in
the bathroom can you guys speak a little
to the style of the movie because I know
the immediate comparison is oh it's it's
like a different version of super bed
but what is it about this that kind of
has that extra layer of style that
people have never seen before
stylistically you know I don't we always
kind of thought of it as or at least
early on thought of it as a
almost like a live-action South Park you
know and that was kind of our model and
then when Seth and Evan and Point gray
came on it you know we were huge fans of
theirs and it definitely helmets a super
bad seeped in but I think that I mean
this is just they're so they're closer
in age to the South Park characters and
they are to the to the super bad
characters that's a genius comparison
like comparing it to a live-action South
Park which I'm surprised I've never
heard anybody at least tried to do that
before it's almost like if you were to
take this nice family movie about these
three kids and just completely drench it
with with a bunch of bad stuff pretty
much yeah so I know in the movie you
guys break your parents drone is that
what happens okay ends up getting stolen
so that so we have to go fetch it I've
actually never used the word fetish all
right I got the wrap-up sign so I wanted
to play a little game with you guys
really quickly and games we are just
calling it Collider random questions
there are just some fun questions that
I'm sure everybody out there wants to
know the answer to first off if you guys
had your choice what TV show would you
want a guest star on the office Rubidoux
probably the office too yeah yeah that's
a good show what do you collect
fingernails my used to collect pokemon
cards are you excited for it detective
Pikachu it looks pretty fun yeah it
looks awesome
I think right he's really funny
I'm pumped for that one what movie do
you guys quote the most quote what does
quote mean like say the lines of
dialogue for the movie Bohemian Rhapsody
I know I know definitely what I get told
the most it's from San LA you're killing
me smalls I get told that a lot have you
ever seen what's it called Friday yeah
yeah Friday there's one line in there
that we always say I forgot can you can
you tell me we can check it out anyway
but anyway Friday I was thinking you
were gonna say Star Wars I was well
actually not really I just quote hmm I
quarrel a lot of different things the
room probably the room not room by room
we also reek whoa what we've already
said on good boys like all the time at
anyer Balaton now do you guys own any
movie or TV show props
why are you stolen anything from set is
basically what we're asking um I do have
this fake box cutter from predator from
the predator yeah I do I do have um I
actually uh stole my earring the earring
I wore an earring in the movie and I got
to keep it I didn't steal it but I got
to keep it so that was cool and I
brought it at the school for a school
project and they were like why do you
have an earring I was like let me
explain so I I couldn't hang on that
project also from room I I got this I
got like you know how I'm Jack gets this
red truck birthday I got that I actually
got that red red um we're all control
truck I have it in my room right now so
that's cool what is the background photo
on your phones my dog
chick-fil-a right now it's the queen
logo oh sweet
I like that Bohemian Rhapsody was one of
my favorite movies the last year so I'm
all for that answer to wrap it up on a
little more serious know it what is the
movie that got you guys interested in
making movies or was it a specific
performance a director you admire
anything mine actually my first thing
was a commercial and it was a New York
Life commercial and then I think after
that I kind of got recognized so I was
kind of going out for auditions and I
booked a TV series called Boardwalk
Empire and I was on that for like four
years I think and I played Tommy Darmody
and it was a Scorsese Direction call
Marty Marty but I just fell in love with
it and it's been my passion ever since I
think just watching well I also started
off with commercials too so I think I
think we just started doing commercials
just as a fun little fun little activity
to do but what what um Tommy it's like
doing movies is I I really enjoy movies
i watch them all the time I think it's
just just watch just watching like
trying to think of a good example of a
movie that I watched like Jaws jaws is
an important one yeah mine is my older
brother do you guys watch movie slither
well no that's at the thing but like got
me into like you know acting my older
brother didn't he do it first yeah cool
guys I am so thankful that you guys came
in today cuz I'm really excited for your
movie good boys keep an eye out for it
another thank you to hint water for
letting this interview happen so psyched
to catch your movie the trailer looks
crazy if you haven't watched it already
check it out online right now like and
share this interview and we will see you
soon with more coverage from South by
Southwest 2019
you